ahora vamos a hacer algunos ejercicios
de la sección de khan academy marcando
datos en gráficas de líneas un grupo de
amigos canguros tenían un concurso de
saltos y midieron su salto más largo
redondeado al medio metro más cercano
aquí están los canguros jumper pocket
auster y joy y aquí está la medición de
su salto más largo cuántos puntos debe
haber en una gráfica de líneas de esas
mediciones vamos a ver aquí abajo nos
dicen crear una gráfica de líneas que
muestre todas las mediciones todas éstas
de acá haz clic arriba de la marca en la
recta numérica que coincida con la
medición haz clic más arriba para
agregar más puntos encima de la misma
marca haz clic más abajo para agregar
menos puntos veamos aquí tenemos la
medición en metros 8 metros 9 metros 10
11 12 13 metros y aquí están estas
marcas que miden la mitad de un metro
veamos nuestro primer canguro jumper
llegó a los 12 metros así que vamos a
hacer clic encima de la marca de los 12
metros
y aquí está la marca de nuestro primer
canguro veamos el siguiente canguro
pocket 10 metros y medio veamos aquí 8
metros 9 metros 10 metros y medio tiene
que estar aquí arriba muy bien luego
sigue
auster ocho y medio metros vemos nuestra
barra ocho y medio metros aquí está la
marca finalmente tenemos a joy que es
alto 11 metros y aquí tenemos 11 metros
entonces ya tenemos gráfica 2 todos los
puntos que corresponden a la distancia
de los saltos que dio cada canguro
entonces cuántos puntos debe haber en
una gráfica de líneas de estas
mediciones pues es un punto por cada
canguro 1 2 3 4 vemos nuestra gráfica y
tenemos 1 2 3 4 van a ser cuatro puntos
y comprobamos nuestra respuesta es
correcta veamos otro problema
la princesa danila me dio la distancia
de sus viajes en alfombra mágica a
varias ubicaciones redondeadas a un
cuarto de milla más cercano
tenemos la ubicación torre del castillo
establo de dragones clase de los
caballeros puente elevadizo y salón de
baile y aquí está la distancia en millas
veamos
cuántos puntos debe haber en una gráfica
de línea de estas mediciones y aquí nos
dicen crear una gráfica de línea que
muestre estas mediciones haz clic a
arriba de la marca en la recta numérica
que coincida con cada medición haz clic
más arriba para agregar más puntos
encima es lo mismo que hicimos en el
ejercicio anterior así que vemos nuestra
recta numérica tiene una milla dos
millas tres millas 4 millas y cada una
de estas millas está dividida en 1 2 3 4
en 4 veamos la primera medición es actor
del castillo que está a una milla y un
cuarto entonces vemos aquí aquí tenemos
una milla y un cuarto nada más avanzamos
hasta acá hacemos clic arriba y aquí
tenemos un punto
luego el siguiente lugar es el establo
de dragones a tres millas y media es un
medio pero no aquí nuestras divisiones
las tenemos en cuartos a cuatro es
equivalente un medio en cuartos bueno si
multiplicamos y dividimos por dos el
numerador y el denominador tenemos que
uno por dos es 2 y este 2 por 2 va a ser
4 entonces un medio es igual a 2 cuartos
el establo de dragones está a una
distancia de 3 millas dos cuartos lo
ponemos en la barra vemos nuestra recta
numérica una milla dos millas tres
millas y dos cuartos aquí es un cuarto y
aquí está el otro cuarto y como ven está
justo a la mitad entre estas dos marcas
son tres millas y media como nos lo dice
aquí la tabla la clase de los caballeros
está a tres millas
pues eso está exacto una milla dos
millas tres millas
aquí está
luego sigue el puente levadizo que está
a dos millas y un cuarto vemos la
gráfica aquí están las dos millas y un
cuarto hacemos clic aquí
finalmente el salón de baile que está a
una milla y tres cuartos de ella
está a una milla y tres cuartos un
cuarto dos cuartos tres cuartos está
aquí entonces lo que nos preguntan
cuántos puntos debe haber en una gráfica
de líneas de estas mediciones contamos
los puntos 1 2 3 4 5 que coinciden con
los datos que están en esta tabla 1 2 3
4 y 5 así que nuestra respuesta es 5
comprobamos respuesta es correcta
hagamos un problema más el centro de
conservación natural midió la
envergadura de todas sus águilas
redondeada al medio centímetro más
cercano cuántos puntos debe haber en una
gráfica de líneas de estas mediciones
recordamos los ejercicios anteriores
sabemos con solo ver cuántos renglones
hay aquí que vamos a tener un punto por
cada uno de estos renglones vamos a
tener un punto para la medición de bald
y otro para flyer otro para wings otro
para federer y otro para vicky
hacer 5 puntos pero de todas maneras
vamos a hacer la gráfica de cada una de
estas mediciones
comenzamos con balde y que tiene 81
centímetros
vamos a ver nuestra gráfica nuestra
recta numérica va de 80 centímetros
hasta los 85 centímetros y tenemos una
marca justo a la mitad de cada
centímetro quedamos entonces que nuestra
primera águila baldi tiene una
envergadura de 81 centímetros así que
vemos aquí 81 centímetros exactitud aquí
ponemos este punto luego sigue flyer que
tiene envergadura de 82 y medio
centímetros buscamos aquí 82 y medio
marcamos aquí en este punto que está a
la mitad
y ahora la envergadura de wings es de 84
y medio centímetros está bastante grande
84 y medio centímetros aquí
luego sigue feder con 80 centímetros
este se ve más pequeñito está aquí al
principio de nuestra recta numérica y
finalmente vicky con 82 centímetros está
aquí y en efecto vemos que tenemos 1 2 3
4 5 puntos así que los puntos que debe
haber en una gráfica de línea de esas
mediciones son 5 y comprobamos nuestra
respuesta
es correcta